Korea,
Brown cofounder,
big thing.
I originally from Toronto and I actually
don't think that it shaped me too much.
I think my parents shaped me more than
where I'm from.
My parents are,
uh,
one is our Schwann is American.
And so we were always,
none of us were Canadians growing up in
Canada.
And so we always were a little bit of
outsiders and so we kind of have that
mentality I think.
No,
sure.
My,
my family is pretty creative and both my
siblings are actors and my sister is
also a writer,
so it's kind of been in the blood and I
knew I wanted to do it from,
you know,
a long time.
It was just a question of having the
courage to kind of go and move to La and
start as an unpaid intern and a waitress
and that type of thing.
So,
um,
I mean I,
I've just kind of known that I wanted to
do it.
I can't think of as precise event that's
told me this is what you will do that,
um,
well,
you know,
what
it did was sort of not about business.
I wanted to do something
entrepreneurial.
And I had wanted to work in the
entertainment and media field.
And so after I graduated from
university,
I moved to France for a year.
And while I was there I decided,
you know,
I'm really interested in film and
Television and that type of thing.
So I moved back to Toronto very briefly
before moving to Los Angeles to work in
film.
And so while I was there,
I thought,
you know,
I don't really want one to work my way
up the studio system.
I'd actually like to be running things
and creating things and having creative
say and what I'm doing.
And so I realized that all too often,
creative people don't really understand
that what they're doing is also a
business.
And so they kind of need to be trained
in that way to operate on the same level
as the business people.
And so I figured I better get some
training in business and so went to
business school.
But it wasn't because I really wanted to
be a business person,
it's just that I wanted to understand
what business people did so that I could
participate.
Okay.